how many oscars has quentin tarantino
won for best director oh that's a great
question i should absolutely have this
down i can say look okay
without answering the question i spin
out
quentin tarantino there's an example of
a director who is
very
singular with his vision and knows
exactly what he wants to
give you as an audience he wants he's
going to give you the film that he has
in his head is going to be the product
and that's the challenge for filmmakers
is what's in the head doesn't always
come out into the end product i think
tarantino maximizes his vision to actual
completion product uh maybe better than
any director i think villeneuve is up
there uh but tarantino's one for sure
and certainly as a director writer i
don't know if there's a better
combination
do you know how many oscars he's won for
best director well i okay i don't have
the exact i'm gonna throw a number out
and say uh
she obviously we know that he was not
happy with bong winning instead of him
that's an interesting story by the way
we get into that or not but there's a
very interesting story with quentin
tarantino and bong very interesting that
i i've never told well first of all
tarantino would probably come after me
guys hold it but it's a good one um but
i okay for me i can say this he should
have won for django unchained
he did not win for django unchained he
should have won i django and chains one
of my favorite tarantino movies um i'm
gonna say he has
well the easy the thing for me is i
really should know is i would say it's
zero but i'm gonna say one
your first your intuition good zero
which is crazy right like i said you
think about django just recently even
once of a time in hollywood but you know
sometimes it's all about what's the
competition you know when you look at
parasite parasite was a phenomenon and
and once you get to that level um where
parasite is just
all-encompassing it's it's going to win
the one thing i think tarantino would
have and this would be this is the
challenge i think for any major
filmmaker um like a tarantino is having
people in your circle who are
capable
and strong enough and you listen to them
you value their opinion to say listen
man your movie needs to be shorter it
needs to be tighter and you have to val
the director at that point has to value
the opinion of the person who's given
him that obviously and i don't know if
every director has that ability to step
back and have other people assess their
work and allow them to
make constructive comments that might
better the film and i think hateful
light is absolute film that's too long
um so many films i see are too long i
mean it's it's it's not
and it's not really about length you
know you could watch a
immaculate three-hour film i mean look
at the wolf of wall street to me uh even
avengers end game um these are films
that at three hours work okay but there
are also also plenty of films that do
not they
they run too long um again go back to
everything everywhere all at once 225.
if that movie comes in at 150 and you
don't have as much repetition at the end
it's a great film as it is it it loses
its value as it extends past
its natural point where it really should
have ended and it's really about
tightening the screws and i think
filmmakers have to have that person in
their life that is
that they value and that they will
listen to and they will make the changes
necessary if they if they believe them
to to be accurate and you got to find
those people you trust in your life i
mean i think in anything you do right
but here's the thing who who's going to
who's going to tell tarantino right
you're scared most people are like i'm
not going to go tell quinn you might go
off on me
i don't i wouldn't have that you have to
have someone who's very again he goes
back to that being
knowing you and your assessment of the
product is accurate at least as much as
you
believe it to be and again
having the instincts to know and then
having the fearlessness to say i said i
would love to do that
listen let me watch your film
and and you could say i'm crazy and what
i'm telling you is absolutely wrong but
at least let me watch it and i will say
hey i think that we can do this this and
this and we can make a stronger product
sometimes maybe there's not nothing to
change but that's not very often it's
it's very
infrequent that i see a film that i
don't go okay i think you could do this
this and this and it would be a stronger
product i thought boyhood was great oh
and some people said it was way too long
and meandered i loved boyhood more than
slacker so yes no boyhood i know that's
maybe not a popular opinion but boyhood
is a film um
was that 2012 13 14 14. a boyhood is a
film that i saw in boston and i'd heard
so many great things about it and and i
sat through it i just had the birth of
of my son
and my daughter was
both extremely young and i'm watching
this film and i'm going
wow this film is just everything the the
sad passage of time is something that
really hits me and when you watch
boyhood you really see that right you
see them the shot over how many years
was that was it was it 15 years 10 years
whatever the length of time they filmed
it i can't remember now it's been so
many years but that that we're going to
go shoot every year a little bit as the
kid grows up as the daughter grows up
and the sad passage of time is something
that will always resonate with me and
boyhood captures that in a way that is
uh it's what makes it the film it is i
mean it's it's really something when you
talk about
filmmaking and what link later did with
that film it just it's uh it's truly one
of the best films because of that
because of what he did the uniqueness of
that
project
who deserves an oscar more tarantino or
nolan
tarantino
yeah i think tarantino again when you
look at
you look at all the films his his
portfolio of films is really with few
exceptions um everything you're going to
get from him is going to be
top shelf now that said i think nolan is
absolutely right there as well i mean
interstellar for me is when you talk
about nolan films i think it's
interstellar and again what does that
hit down on it drills down on the sad
passage of time right so he comes back
and his daughter now is he's he stayed
the same age that that just blew me away
uh but there are things that nolan does
that i go listen i don't know what your
thinking is this is what we talked about
someone needs to get to christopher
nolan and say listen i know you want to
mess with audio i get it i know you want
to play with that it's artistic you want
to do this strange thing and experiment
with the audio you do not experiment
with the audio
i.e dialogue of a film that is in
ud dialogue to explain
films such as interstellar such as tenet
you better have that dialogue tenant
without the dialogue you're like people
are like what's going on here but he
buries it
behind ludwig's score
um and hansa scored an interstellar i
remember sitting there an interstellar
and even batman
um the dark knight rises
i remember sitting in that screening
early this was a press reading so it was
a before it came out and i'm sitting
there in this giant imax theater in
boston going
why am i not hearing the dialogue
this is weird because it's usually
dialed in here the something's
something's off in here
and that was i think one of his first
things that he started to mess with the
audio dark knight rises and then you go
to interstellar remember that was a big
story everyone was going nolan people
don't come to us and complain the
theaters were like don't come to us and
say that the sound's not right nolan did
that it's not our fault you shouldn't be
doing that i don't know what his thought
process is i mean i get it he's
experimenting but don't do that because
it's lessening your films and i think
that again that gets back to what we say
these filmmakers need to have somebody
who is going to come up to them like i
just
said here
stop messing with the audio and your
dialogue especially in these films that
need it you need somebody who has that
you value that tells you this is a
mistake because it is it is um he might
think it's cool you might think it's
it's an interesting thing to do but it
is it's making the it's lessening the
film and that's what we say it's like
the choices you make ultimately either
make the film better or worse and
nolan's experimentation of audio makes
his films worse
i'm going to name seven directors i'm
hoping you can tell me which one has won
an oscar for best director
number one spike lee
number two paul thomas anderson
number three ridley scott
four david fincher five robert altman
six alfred hitchcock seven stanley
kubrick
this is another one of these trick
questions i know it where you're these
are these are this is a gigantic list of
incredible directors that go back
through the the history of um you talk
about the vaunted uh directors of all
time and we're going to end up with like
one oscar winner right i can't fool you
yeah yeah it's not fully but here's
that's this is what this is what's crazy
about this is that is that is is is
that's the maddening part of oscars and
awards is that it doesn't always go to
the best person in the list we just had
of these directors preeminent directors
of all time
and and the number is what a grand total
of is it even two
uh there's seven and i believe the
number is zero i'm just gonna say it's
good it's fine
is it even two yeah i was trying to say
possibly out of all these directors
we've got to have two that but that's
but that's that goes wow what what's
happening here
but again i think you have to go back
and look at the films that they had that
were their best film and let's just use
fincher because it's recent um and we go
to social network
and you say um
he's he's in the right place and you
just go how did this not happen because
there's something else that caught fire
it happens so often in award season
where you have something all of a sudden
gets momentum and then it just goes
snowballs up coda just happened that's
exactly what happened to koda it was
really a movie that no one was talking
about as even an awards film really a
major player when apple acquired that
out of sundance coda was sitting there
they put it out i believe in august of
last year and everyone was like that's
fine it's fine you know we like the film
it's good but then it kind of went away
and then apple said we're going to
really attack this film
as an fyc film as an oscars film and
let's push this and it started getting
momentum it started winning here and
here but if you go back
at coding you look speaking of directors
and you look at sean hader who directed
that film i don't believe she has a
single nomination from any critics group
anywhere which is really unheard of for
a film
you know when you talk about a best
picture you're at least talking about a
director that's in the conversation
um and i think
that that's a real rare occurrence when
you look at coda but a lot of times it's
really about timing these these
directors had something that caught a
film that caught fire up against them
and it was that director's moment but
the fact that you have zero is just it's
i know that's it's baffling because you
you go back and you go how is that
possible
um but you'd have to go back and look at
every year and say what was it what was
the film that came through and like
king's speech and just was like oh it's
king's speech and you're like
it's the king's speech really you're
kidding me no but as you go back you
assess it and you're like that was the
wrong decision i mean it was
objectively which which films stan stood
the test of time king's speech or social
network okay
i mean any even tarantino i believe even
recently said social network is his best
film of the past decade and probably
beyond and again i'm not it's not my
best film of the past decade and beyond
for me because of quentin tarantino but
i love hearing when another director
says the same thing that's awesome
you know and i'm going to say an
unpopular opinion i love molly's game
more yep
maybe just a female protagonist so
identified more but i absolutely love
that but don't forget that's sorkin
directing
ah okay so so so that's sorkin directing
good point right so but you know it's
interesting here so okay let's talk
about that's i love you brought that up
because when you talk about director and
screenwriter the combination not every
director is a good writer and not every
writer is a good director okay when you
look at aaron sorkin you look at a
writer who is one of the best if not the
best working in hollywood today right
and you give him a script such as social
network and then you couple that
with david fincher direction
and you get social network then you flip
it and you go to trial to chicago seven
and you get aaron sorkin writing and you
get
aaron sorkin directing and you don't get
anywhere near not even in the same
universe
and it speaks to i think that these are
two different skills direction and
writing are not the same skills and i
think there are some director writers
that maybe should just be directing or
maybe just should be writing
and i think aaron sorkin has yet for me
to prove that he's at certainly at a
fincher level but few are but but still
maybe you know
maybe you're just a writer maybe you're
just a director um there's directors
i've seen that have written and you're
just like i i saw something recently
where i said i think that if you give if
you would have directed this and let
someone else write the script uh it
would have been better i mean there's
something's gonna pop in my head but but
again those are two distinct skills and
and i think we have a bleeding sometimes
and sometimes you can't do it all maybe
you can but the chances are lower the
more that you try to do that's well
write direct act you can have someone
who does all these things well i mean
clooney has had some good films
directorially and he's been in uh but
but i think it's hard it's really hard
to get all of those skills because these
are all different things you're juggling
three completely different things
ben affleck and argo 100
oh he he shows the instinct right there
right ben affleck and argo uh you know
argo's a fantastic film a crowd pleaser
all these things and and he he shows
a ton of talent then you go look at this
movie that he did uh like a few years
after that i'm forgetting it now it's
like a warner brothers film period piece
with him and um
uh but it was not a great film so it's
again it gets back to you can have one
great film that doesn't mean every film
you ever make for the rest of time is
going to be great
and and that's the importance of when
you go down to watch a film and sit down
is to forget all that you know about the
director and what you're about to see
and just evaluate what is there on the
screen not who's behind the camera
what is on the screen
and i think there are people in this
business film critics who get bogged
down in who's the director this this and
this i'm like it doesn't matter
ultimately it doesn't matter when you
think about it
it's it's really about the final product
period
you